Transcription: Leon Delaloye
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Oups, wow !
Quel gros public j’ai là, devant moi.
Wow !
C’est vrai que je n’arrive encore pas
à me détacher
de notre monde de slam et de comédie.
Mais je vais quand même vous dire
qu’aujourd’hui, avant d’être là, j’étais
à une cérémonie de baptême.
Et là, j’ai rencontré deux messieurs
qui ont quand même préféré
ne pas m’aborder
et ils ont juste attendu
que je sois très loin
et ils se demandaient
entre eux, en malinké :
Il y en a un qui dit : « [en malinké] »
Ça veut dire en français :
« Mon ami, elle est blanche ou albinos ? »
Bon, vu la tête que vous faites,
j’espère que vous avez
au moins pu faire la nuance
parce que le monsieur
nous a aidé, là, notre modérateur.
Alors est-ce que quelqu’un peut
quand même imaginer ce que ça fait
d’être la plus jeune speaker
de cette après-midi ?
Vous pouvez imaginer !
Ou même d’être la seule étudiante
de tous les speakers,
Ou encore mieux, d’être la seule personne
atteinte d’albinisme de toute la salle.
Wow !
J’ai envie de vous dire [ confus ]
mais bon, j’en passe.
(Applaudissements)
Alors d’après vous,
pendant que je suis là,
je devrais plutôt me
sentir fière de moi,
parce que vous savez,
à l’instant où je vous parle,
la plupart de mes amis
sont en classe en train d’étudier.
Donc je devais déjà
être fière de moi d’être là,
ou vous pensez plutôt
que je devais m’estimer chanceuse ?
Oui, parce que vous savez,
entre guillemets, les albinos,
en Afrique, surtout en Guinée ici,
ils sont plus fréquents dans les rues
que dans les conférences, par exemple.
Ou vous pensez plutôt que j’ai un, ou même
des défis à relever cet après-midi ?
Qu’est-ce que vous pensez ?
Bon d'accord, c'est vrai que ça m'aurait
fait grand plaisir d'en parler avec vous.
Sauf que le sujet de cet après-midi,
ce n’est pas moi en tant que telle,
mais nous !
Nous, personnes atteintes
d’albinisme d’Afrique.
On va appeler les choses par leur nom,
nous, albinos d’Afrique.
Vous voyez, ces êtres de parents noirs,
à la peau blanche comme ça,
qui ont généralement
de petits boutons noirs
et parfois même des plaies.
Ceux qui ont des poils
et des cheveux blonds
avec des yeux multicolores
qui bougent dans tous les sens,
comme les aiguilles d’une montre.
Ceux qu’on croise généralement
dans les rues en train de mendier.
Ceux à qui on remet généralement
les sacrifices des féticheurs
et desmarabouts des quartiers.
Ceux qui se font tout le temps humilier,
rejeter,
parfois même kidnapper et mutiler
pour des raisons mysticieuses
dans certains pays.
Vous voyez de qui je parle ?
Oui, je sais que vous voyez
de qui je parle.
Mais en réalité, que savez-vous d’eux ?
De ces personnes que vous voyez ?
De leurs sentiments
ou même de leurs conditions de vie ?
Est-ce que vous vous êtes au moins
intéressé à eux,
ne serait-ce que pour une fois ?
Je sais que la plupart
des gens diront oui.
Ou du moins très peu de gens diront oui,
ou d’autres diront non,
pour plusieurs raisons.
Peut-être parce
qu’ils ne les connaissent pas
ou parce qu’ils ont peur d’eux.
Oui, en Afrique, quand on est albinos,
on fait peur aux autres
parce qu’on n’arrive pas
à concevoir le fait
que quelqu’un qui a une couleur
extrêmement blanche
puisse sortir de deux parents noirs.
Donc on est vu comme étrange
et donc comme des sorciers,
des petits diables,
parfois même porte-bonheur
ou porte-malheur, fétiche de la famille…
En tout cas, tout ce qui est loin d’être
un être humain normal.
Et la conséquence directe,
c'est la discrimination.
Alors vivre dans une société
où les gens se crachent dessus
comme ça en les voyant,
où certains les fuient comme ça,
sans raison,
ils ont même peur de les toucher.
Être traité comme une créature
surnaturelle,
ne pas pouvoir sortir à des heures
où tout le monde peut sortir,
ne pas pouvoir fréquenter des endroits
que tout le monde peut fréquenter,
être privé de choses
dont la plupart des gens ont droit,
croyez moi, peu importe leur rang social,
la plupart des albinos d’Afrique
en connaissent le goût.
Je sais de quoi je parle.
Et alors, oui, quand on n’est pas traité
comme un être humain normal,
ce sont nos libertés qui sont fragilisées
et nos droits bafoués.
Et dans la plupart des cas,
même les autorités publiques
peinent à stabiliser les conditions de vie
des personnes atteintes d’albinisme,
parfois par manque de stratégie,
parfois par manque de moyens,
parfois même par manque de volonté.
Encore plus dommage.
Et il est vrai que se faire rejeter
par sa famille,
ça fait perdre confiance en soi.
Oui, se sentir comme un étranger chez soi,
ça fait perdre des opportunités
et parfois même,
ça peut faire perdre le goût à la vie.
Mais fort heureusement,
je le dis bien fort heureusement,
au beau milieu
de toute cette grande désolation,
il y en a quand même qui n’ont pas voulu
accepter le sort commun.
Ils n’ont pas voulu baisser les bras.
À travers leurs actions,
leurs aspirations,
leur façon d’être, leur façon de faire,
ils ont inspiré leurs semblables
grâce à leur talent
et une grande persévérance,
ils ont même réussi à graver
leur nom dans l’histoire.
Ils sont nombreux.
Peut-être que vous connaissez
certains d’entre eux, ou peut-être pas.
Mais de Salif Keita, par exemple,
à Monsieur Kabinet Camara,
je vois déjà son homologue
qui est là, du CNT
ou à tant d’autres personnes
atteintes d’albinisme
qui ont quand même réussi
à prendre leur destin en main malgré tout
et à se frayer un chemin.
Et peut-être que je n’ai pas cité assez
d’exemples ou de modèles de ces personnes,
et peut-être que je n’ai pas suffisamment
parlé d’eux, de leurs conditions de vie
ou de leur quotidien.
Mais j’espère sincèrement que vous êtes
d’accord avec moi
sur le fait qu’ils aient pris
la bonne décision
en prenant leur destin en main
malgré tout.
Vous êtes d’accord avec moi,
n’est-ce pas ?
Alors j’espère que vous le prouverez
désormais à travers vos actions,
en luttant à leurs côtés pour leurs droits
et leur promotion,
en prônant leur intégration
à votre façon sur tous les plans.
J’espère que durant un court instant,
aussi court qu’il soit, là, devant vous,
vous avez pu voir une jeune fille,
ou une étudiante,
ou même une speaker,
comme tous les autres ici,
et non une albinos tout court.
Parce que vous savez quoi ?
En fin de compte, je suis vous.
Vous êtes moi,
enfin, nous sommes nous, quoi !
Nous sommes Guinéens, Africains, Humains.
Et puis ça va !
Et sachez que notre Afrique
primitive et exclusive
cède lentement mais largement sa place
à une Afrique nouvelle et évolutive.
Alors chérissez cette Afrique nouvelle
et soyez acteur de son évolution.
En ce qui me concerne,
mes quelques mots étaient censés
vous permettre de lire dans mes idées
afin de connaître éventuellement
mes intentions,
pour que désormais ce soit
vous qui nous rendez forts
envers et contre tout.
Et si j’ai failli quelque part,
soyez indulgents et ne tenez compt
que de l’intention,
car dans le fond, il n’y a qu’elle
qui compte réellement.
Et quoi qu’il arrive, retenez toujours
que l’altitude d’un être humain
est déterminée par son attitude
et son aptitude
et non pas par son physique.
Je vous remercie.